with a flotation device and extensive
training you can spend roughly 48 hours
in the sea before conditions overpower
you
life jacket life buoy and their floating
devices allow us 48 hours to save their
life
so tomorrow will be the highlight we'll
try to do as much as we can to save them
the htms Asuka Thai Corvette sank on
Sunday it's now merged that there
weren't enough flotation devices on
board for the amount of sailors the ship
was carrying an extra 30 Personnel were
on board as part of the operation it was
on for those who did manage to survive
the ordeal has been horrific
we found this guy holding live boy so he
rescued him he was floating in the water
for 10 hours he is still conscious so we
could take him out of the water safely
pain tragedy struck Sunday night as
strong winds blew sea water onto the
deck and knocked out the ship's
electricity the loss of power allowed
more sea water to flow into the vessel
overpowering it and eventually sinking
it the authorities sprung into action
dispatching three frigates and two
helicopters as part of the rescue
efforts
a 48-hour window is closing and after
that rescue efforts will turn into
recovery operations as brutal sea
conditions could overpower those left in
the water Imran Khan Al Jazeera